مأساة في ضواحي العاصمة الأوكرانية
لقي 17 شخصًا مصرعهم بمن فيهم
وزير الداخلية الأوكراني بعد
تحطم طائرة هليكوبتر بالقرب من روضة أطفال في
مبان سكنية شرق أربعة أطفال رئيسيين
من بين القتلى مع 11 آخرين
يتلقون العلاج في المستشفى مباشرة
إلى جائزة كريس سانتا الحية لنا
في  المشهد الآن في أوكرانيا ، ما الذي
تراه
عمال كلاريسا في مكان الحادث هنا ، لقد قاموا
بتمشيط هذا المبنى لساعات
الآن في محاولة للتأكد من عدم وجود
أي شخص آخر بالداخل لأن
هذا هو المكان الذي تحطمت فيه المروحية ،
تم قطع المبنى خلفي تمامًا
ثم  سقطت المروحية في
الملعب في الجزء الخلفي من
روضة الأطفال ، نعلم أن جميع
الأشخاص التسعة الذين كانوا على متن المروحية
بما في ذلك وزير داخلية هذا البلد
دينيس ووزارات ونائب
وزير الداخلية ووزير الدولة
بوزارة الداخلية بالإضافة إلى ستة
آخرين في  على متن تلك المروحية
، قُتلوا جميعًا على الفور أيضًا
بين دي  الأطفال والآباء الذين
كانوا يجلبون أطفالهم إلى المدرسة هنا ،
لقد تحدثت إلى امرأة قالت
إنها لم تر الحادث الذي سمعته
وأنه عندما خرجت نحو
روضة الأطفال رأت الأطفال يتم
إنقاذهم من مكان الحادث.  كان من بينهم
حرفيًا مشتعلًا على ارتفاع أعلى لأن وقود الطائرات
أدى إلى حريق هائل وعندما
وصل فريقنا إلى مكان الحادث
رأى ما لا يقل عن أربع جثث على الأرض ،
كان هناك حطام في كل مكان
من المروحية رأيناهم
يزيلون بعض القطع الكبيرة من
المروحية في الساعة الماضية فقط ، لكن حتى الآن
لا نعرف حتى الآن سبب ذلك ، كان
الطقس سيئًا هذا الصباح قال رجل آخر
إنه كان يدخن سيجارة في
شرفته ولم يستطع حتى
أن يسمع صوت الانهيار فقط لأنه
كان الضباب كثيفًا للغاية ولكننا لا نعرف حتى الآن بشكل
قاطع السلطات هنا تقول
إنها تبحث في كل
زاوية محتملة ولكن لا داعي
للقول إن يومًا مأساويًا حقًا في بلد
عانى بالفعل من الكثير.  رعب
الكثير من الحزن وفقدان الكثير